can you call Paul Rudd right now if you
want it and he'd answer
it's possible
yeah he's that good a friend would you
say he's the top 10 friends of in your
life
um yeah maybe in in terms of
uh the whole of my life he's up there
talk about a guy talk about
um
uh loyalty
first of all what did did you just meet
him but you met him before white hot
American or did he audition
we I knew I sort of knew him through
Zach orth because Zach or Zach the best
that's not the best Zach orth had been
in the boss Lerman Romeo and Juliet yes
with Paul uh in the late 90s and
basically Zach invited him to see this
weird little play that me and Michael
shelter and joluchulia wrote called sex
AKA wieners and boobs remember that 99
and uh he came and was just like oh my
God whatever you guys your stick is
right up my alley and so we basically at
the time were trying to figure out how
to get wet Hot American Summer put
together and we said would you you know
attach your and he wasn't a name then no
no not really not really he had been in
200 Cigarettes and he had been in he was
in Clueless uh yes and he also had
played the Romantic lead in um object of
My Affection with Jennifer Aniston so he
was not in big name at all but he was
enough of a name for us to like say like
it would be value added to our project
if you would be part of it so you just
offered him the part so we offered him a
part and I didn't really know him or his
work that well quite honestly
um but I knew I liked what I had seen
and I was like that's great it'd be
awesome if you were part of it and so
um yeah and then I didn't really really
get to know him until he came to set to
do Wet Hot American Summer were you
Blown Away by how good he was how funny
he was I have to admit I was less I was
like he's okay I really didn't get it
until I was in editing really I that and
and it was only then that I was like oh
this guy's otherworldly you know and
then since and then since then and I was
lucky enough to I think make five movies
in a row with Paul and every [__]
take every time like you're just like
this guy is the magic like he's he's
really quite something you know what's
amazing is what you just said as a
director you're watching him on set and
you're going yeah whatever yeah and then
you're editing and you're finding out
the genius
it reminds me of that that show the
offer did you see the offer no it's the
making of um
The Godfather and the studio Robert
Evans was like looking at the Dale he
didn't want Pacino he says no this guy's
no good Bob was a good friend was he
just too many people I'm sure too many
people sure but he watched the dailies
and he's like this this is crap this is
what is he doing and it wasn't until
later when they put it together but they
put the genius together yeah so but how
do you
how do you know that you don't know well
I mean everything yeah so many things
just come with experience and there's
just no substitute for understanding
that but yeah with Paul I don't know I
mean I mean I think I was making my
first movie and I was thinking about a
thousand things and you know I just
didn't really clock how great he was and
uh but in post like I said you're just
like looking at them like oh my God this
guy's like working on a different level
and then over the years working very
closely with him and you know starring
in movies that you know we're working
together writing together I just see how
his
you know and it seems so
he's not the kind of guy that talks
about his process that much or like is
very uh highfalutin about it at all and
I mean I have memories of working on
things where he's playing you know
Scrabble on his phone and until like
after we've said action I'm like put
your phone away it's time to start he's
like all right okay and then just boom
boom and he's in the like so in it and
so real and so funny
and also he'll give you in four takes
he'll give you four completely different
but all great and usable options for
this amazing you know it's it's a and it
really makes you appreciate you know as
me as someone who's done the a fair
amount of acting but never really
been great at it and like understand
like just the appreciation for that art
form is just you know when you see
someone who just has that thing you know
what are you gonna do DiCaprio
has that he was doing What's Eating
Gilbert Grape yeah and they say that he
would just be in like ah mama you know
he like but first he'd be like joking
farting and laughing and doing all these
things on stage and actually he's like I
don't know if you and he would get into
this character like that yeah
and that is
it's amazing and I think that a lot of
people have to do that I can't sit there
and stew in the part and just constantly
thinking of the heart I'm best when I'm
just talking to people joking around and
action and then I could jump into it if
I'm thinking about things too much it's
not going to be as good yeah when
everyone has a different way to get
there and they're all legitimate and
I've learned that too every actor has a
different process and that's great you
know and I've done some of my favorite
acting of myself when I'm directing at
the same time because I'm not it
prevents me from overthinking it right
and so if I'm thinking about everything
else and then it's just action then I'm
just like doing it yeah you're like the
Hitchcock
filmmaking that's right the Hitchcock of
filmmaking yeah thank you